alors nous sommes aujourd'hui dans le
grand salon qui se situe au
rez-de-chaussée de la demeure familiale
et dans cette pièce se trouve une grande
cheminée
ce qui est assez rare dans
l'architecturé créole des grandes
demeures
alors c'est qui est intéressant avec
cette cheminée c'est qu'au dessus se
trouve une pendule une très très belle
pendule qui est protégée sous une cloche
de verre
alors cette pendule est en marbre et en
bronze doré
d'ailleurs on peut dire qu'ils y
allaient de batin à la fois un bronze de
couleur foncée et puis cette dorures qui
recouvre en partie certains éléments des
des figurines qui sont représentées sur
7 sur cette pendule dans la partie haute
de la pendule donc se trouve un aigle
aux ailes déployées et qui est une
représentation d'une divinité
gréco-romaine zoss donc cette règle
tient dans ses serres 1 la tribu la
tribu de la divinité qui s'appelle le
foudre qui représente un faisceau de dar
enflammé en forme de zig zag
donc on voit que cette pendule tout de
suite faire référence à l'antiquité et
notamment à représentation du panthéon
des dieux de l'antiquité de chaque côté
du du cadran on observe également de
figure un jeune garçon est une jeune
fille
ce qui est clair qu'on le regarde ses
statuts on voit encore l'influencent de
l'antiquité de l'antiquité gréco-romaine
ne serait ce que par rapport aux tenues
vestimentaires et également les
les coiffures ces deux figures et donc
forme avec le cadran donc cette cette
grande composition triangulaire est
juste au dessus du cadran on voit une
black une plaque effectivement en relief
en décor repoussé et qui représente 2 2
ans que l'on appelle les poutine et
george avec leur zèle qu'ils sont en
train de jouer ou de s'amuser sans doute
avec une avec une colombe dans la partie
basse de la pendule
on voit également un décor en frise
réalise également en bronze doré
représentant au centre un masque à roues
qui est maintenue par deux personnages
qui sont à la fois des anges et des îles
sorte de rinceaux végétalisant et puis
deux médaillons de part et d'autre avec
aussi à un masque représentant sans
doute une figure mythologique
alors cette pendule et date de la fin du
xviiie siècle elle a connu un certain
succès sous le règne de louis saez et
donc effectivement cela témoigne de cet
engouement pour cette représentation où
on s'entraîne très nettement l'affluence
de l'art de l'antiquité